il y a quelques années tu as 12 ans
exactement tu as 12 ans tu es en
vacances c'est ça et on sait pas comment
tu as l'idée de créer un compte Twitter
pas comme les autres c'est quoi
exactement en fait je m'ennuie en
vacances j'ai 12 ans donc le premier
réflexe pour un enfant stage là c'est
d'aller voir sur Twitter si jamais
crashman a un compte non
parce qu'en fait non plus sérieusement
en fait et je m'ennuie complètement et à
l'époque il y a beaucoup de comptes
parodiques de plein de de plein
d'animateurs bien sûr et par exemple il
y avait Stéphane Plaza qui Claire Chazal
enfin il y a vraiment plein d'animateurs
enfin voilà et moi je vais regarder
j'avais vu que je ne crashman il y avait
quasiment pas de compte d'accord et je
me suis dit bah vas-y je vais partir sur
Jean-Luc Reichmann d'accord très bien
donc tu pars sur Jean-Luc Reichmann tu
crées quelconque je crée un compte qui
s'appelle Jean-Luc Reichmann le arobase
c'est Luc Reichmann mais par contre ce
qui est important de préciser c'est que
dès le début la première seconde de mon
compte est créé il y a écrit dans ma
biographie compte parodique voilà ça a
aucun moment ma volonté va là-bas aucun
moment ma volonté c'est de me faire
passer pour lui vraiment à 100% comme de
l'usure passion c'est ça exactement à la
base c'était quoi l'objectif c'était
juste faire une oh à la base je m'ennuie
je voulais je voulais juste faire un
truc drôle en me disant que j'allais
mettre torse nu de ce coup de midi puis
voilà quoi exactement très bien alors au
début quel type de contenu tu publies tu
publies des conneries ouais bah comme un
enfant de 12 ans quoi en fait au début
je mets
des trucs un peu n'importe comment je
dis ouais ce soir je vais manger une
paella ça va être délicieux je suis en
train de décortiquer mes crevettes c'est
toujours avec un langage très soutenu
très simple même à 12 ans voilà les gens
pouvaient tomber dans le panneau même si
c'était clairement pas crédible quoi
enfin voilà j'écrive aussi à Julien Doré
vous me faites penser à une libellule
pendant ce moment
constamment vous en octrinez
dans la peau du personnage je me suis
mis dans la peau quand même du
personnage mais je sais très bien
normalement que les gens ne vont pas
tomber dans le panneau et les gens
voyaient pas compte parodique tout de
suite donc
les gens moi en fait j'étais stupéfé
parce que même à l'époque je me dis
ferme-moi à 12 ans je vois un compte je
vois Jean-Luc Reichmann qui dit qui est
en train de préparer une paella et qu'il
est dévasté parce qu'elle est tombée au
sol je commence quand même à tilter que
c'est pas forcément le vrai compte ça
peut passer je te jure ouais ouais mais
ça peut passer et le fait que c'est très
bien passé et qu'en fait le compte a
pris une ampleur mais énorme assez vite
ouais en fait et au fur et à mesure
mettez les tweets et je me disais bon
bah de plus en plus gros ça passe on
sentait encore plus encore plus et puis
bah il y a un jour où j'ai fait un tweet
qui a commencé un peu à me propulser mon
compte en fait c'est je me posais une
question voilà parce qu'elle obspot une
question voilà moi à propos de lui
vraiment me ronger l'esprit il savait
pas si il se laver le crâne avec du
shampoing ou du gel douche donc je me
suis dit je dois lui demander si il se
lave le crâne avec du shampoing du gel
douche et ben voilà le résultat c'est
parce que le bistro en fait tu as fini
par me par me bloquer normalement contre
creusement il a pas voulu répondre à ma
question donc encore aujourd'hui je suis
rongé par la question s'il pourrait s'il
peut me répondre c'est ouf je suis
preneur quoi parce que là je recule la
nuit et donc cette question lui il est
persuadé que c'est Jean-Luc Reichmann
parce que visiblement pour me bloquer en
tout cas c'est qu'il avale le prix je
sais pas si il a cru que c'était le vrai
dans le classement du panne en tout cas
il a pas aimé ce il a il a pas aimé
cette vidéo non non non non
merci voilà c'est la question des des
personnes qui
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui te
répondent qu'est-ce qu'ils disent énorme
personne qui me répondent en fait je
mets beaucoup de tweets voilà parfois
vraiment pour dire n'importe quoi enfin
j'avais même dit un moment que Jean-Luc
Reichmann elle est censée dans la
musique et qu'il allait faire un une
chanson sur son petit toutou armoricain
qui s'appelait Bobby enfin voilà
exactement enfin j'avais vraiment
n'importe quoi tu veux sortir un album
de la musique afin de pouvoir exprimer
toutes les choses qui me tiennent à cœur
mon premier titre se nommera ou adorable
petit toutou en hommage mon petit chien
et là tu as 12 ans là c'est 2018 non
2018 voilà 2018 j'avais pris en maturité
je me suis dit maintenant on passe de la
paella au toutou
on voit un changement directement d'âge
à 16 ans voilà ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose je pense de très naturel on a
repris un tweet de toi mais en fait oui
justement c'est passé c'est qu'en 2017
Jean-Luc Reichman est venu sur le
plateau et ce soir là en fait j'étais à
table et j'étais en train de manger et
tout et puis mon téléphone il se met à
vibrer mais vraiment beaucoup trop que
ce soit juste voilà une coïncidence ou
quoi et vraiment j'arrive même plus à
déverrouiller mon téléphone tellement il
se met à vibrer la vibrer la vibrer et
je vais sur Twitter et je vois j'ai
14000 abonnés d'un coup je me dis c'est
beaucoup et je vais dans les
notifications et je vois mais des
messages mais t'inqui apparaissent et
vraiment à peine j'actualise il y en a
trois quatre nouveaux et tout le monde
me dit oh là là merci beaucoup Siri il
est trop gentil de t'avoir fait de la
pub c'est j'adore votre duo vous êtes
mes deux présentateurs préférés enfin
voilà et je commence à recevoir plein de
messages plein de messages regarde là
il faut que je reste sur Twitter ou pas
alors puisque Jean-Luc vient de se
mettre sur Twitter Jean-Luc Reichmann
j'aimerais qu'on arrive à 30 000 avant
la fin de l'émission tu penses que c'est
allez allez on y va je pense que ça peut
je pense que c'est possible ah ouais
c'est possible 30 000 on va voir on fera
un point dans un instant avec plaisir je
le sens bien alors donc on a mis ton
compte donc Cyril merci beaucoup déjà ah
oui parce que merci beaucoup parce que
du coup bah à ce moment-là j'ai pris à
peu près 12 13000 abonnés je pense dans
la soirée
j'ai reçu plein de messages et en fait
ce qui est aussi un truc assez important
à noter en fait c'est que avant
justement ce ce passage où bah du coup
j'ai eu pas mal de pub en fait quelques
quelques mois avant j'avais fait un
tweet je me disais mon abonnés il
augmente plus enfin voilà et puis de
toute façon je peux pas pouvoir faire
durer la supercherie trop longtemps
enfin les gens vont se rendre compte
qu'à un moment bon bien sûr c'est pas
crédible j'avais fait un tweet j'avais
dit bonjour à tous Voilà je vous révèle
la vérité je suis un enfant de 13 ans et
demi qui qui voilà juste créer ce compte
ça prend une ampleur de fou mais voilà
je ne suis pas Jean-Luc Reichman je suis
un enfant de 13 ans et demi je me suis
dit voilà c'est terminé et là
tout le monde ne répond mais quand je
dis tout le monde c'est une quarantaine
de personnes mais non Jean-Luc ne vous
rabaissez pas vous n'êtes pas un enfant
de 13 ans et demi
[Musique]
coup de midi j'ai participé au de ce
coup de midi en fait il vous a grillé à
ce moment-là non pas du tout en fait moi
ce qui se passe c'est que en gros pour
recontextualiser le tout moi depuis un
an je fais des des tournages en fait
avec des youtubeurs de base et de fil en
aiguille j'ai gardé des contacts
donc j'ai fait de plus en plus de
tournage etc et puis bah on se fait de
plus en plus de contacts on m'a proposé
de faire les douze coups de midi et moi
j'ai directement pensé à ce qui s'était
passé justement on va pendant l'émission
enfin parce que c'était passé avant avec
mon compte twitter je me suis dit c'est
trop marrant il faut que je le fasse en
fait même c'est juste une private joke
je suis obligé même pour moi dans ma
conscience de me dire je vais être face
à Jean-Luc Reichmann sur son plateau il
sait pas que la personne qui l'a en face
de lui c'est le gars qui qui fait chier
quoi et du coup je participe à
l'émission évidemment il ne sait pas que
c'est moi et d'ailleurs il me pose une
question sur les réseaux sociaux il
demande est-ce que je suis branché sur
les réseaux et à ce moment là je réponds
énormément avec un sourire mais
jusqu'aux oreilles parce que au fond de
moi oui lui ne sais pas pourquoi je suis
très branché sur les réseaux mais moi je
sais pourquoi alors c'était assez gênant
parce que en fait
regardez les questions quand c'était au
12 coups de midi
sneakers gamer en plein développement de
son propre jeu étudiant STAPS Louis
douille dans les Yvelines Louis 19 ans
il vient de nouilles pour vous au Japon
depuis juin dernier qu'est-ce qui peut
vous coûter jusqu'à 1 an de prison et
2000 € d'amende soit
mentir sur son statut covid sois l'autre
je vais dire l'autre insulter un
internaute vous êtes branché sur les
réseaux énormément et ben ouais
absolument faut pas faire n'importe quoi
sur les réseaux parce que ça peut faire
des dégâts collatéraux et c'est pas
chouette Louis
tops sur les réseaux sociaux
tu l'as jamais dit à Jean-Luc je l'ai
jamais dit à Jean-Luc et en fait je
pense que je pense qu'il aurait bien
pris j'espère vraiment qu'il l'a bien
pris parce que c'est vraiment une blague
allez j'appelle parce que c'est comme ça
au moins on saura j'appelle Jean-Luc ça
serait vraiment le boucler la boucle
allez vas-y j'appelle Jean-Luc comme ça
c'est fait
allez on l'appelle en direct ah il a pas
l'air en France
deuxième sonnerie je rappelle que nous
appelons Jean-Luc Reichmann pour la
somme de 3500
il doit être en train de dormir
ok tu restes en clientèle
et lui dire ou pas en fait le en fait
moi mon rêve ça aurait été dû dire
clairement mais j'ai pas osé lui dire le
jour du tournage enfin le jour de
l'émission parce que je savais pas
comment ça pouvait après voilà se passer
quoi et bon alors tu as fait plein de
tweets et toi donc c'était tu as
toujours laissé compte parodique même
quand tu avais toujours toujours parce
que enfin moi mon principe de base c'est
vraiment de faire des blagues c'est pas
du tout me faire passer pour lui non
mais c'est pas méchant c'était en plus
attention en plus le plus important
vraiment parce que j'ai vu justement
je suis passé en fait il y a quelques
jours mon anecdote en fait elle a pris
de l'ampleur parce que je suis passé sur
la chaîne Youtube de youtubeur qui
s'appelle Sarcos exactement mon anecdote
c'est ça justement à tout le monde et
bah évidemment ça fait rire tout le
monde enfin la quasi-totalité des gens
était mort de rire et il y a juste en
fait les articles ensuite qui sont
sortis en ligne qui disait Louis le
candidat usurpateur enfin vraiment dans
la vie totale et justement c'est pour
rappeler
plein de messages bizarres sur les
réseaux est-ce que vous on vous envoyer
des dinguerie sur le compte de Jean-Luc
Reichmann il y a des gens qui m'ont
envoyé leur tête en gros plan mais bon
je pense pas que ce soit un truc de fou
mais par contre il a souvent des gens
qui me faisaient des dessins ouais et
après est-ce que je peux vous donner 12
coups de midi moi je répondais pas bien
sûr apporter le moins quand vous passez
donc vous recevoir au moins 5 6 dessins
de qui mettaient destinés en fait
est-ce que vous avez été en relation
avec des amis des vrais amis de Jean-Luc
Reichmann ou des gens des stars de TF1
par exemple qui pensaient que c'était
lui alors j'ai contacté en fait du coup
bah parce que l'opission mais c'est pas
TF1 mais j'ai j'avais écrit Jean-Pierre
Pernaut pendant le JT de 13h à l'époque
et Jean-Pierre Pernaut pendant le lycée
entre deux réponses entre deux
reportages m'a répondu et en plus je
vais faire un truc bon alors vraiment
voilà c'était clairement pas crédible
quoi
mon chéri toujours vraiment il m'avait
répondu mais son plateau il y a vraiment
plein plein de monde il y a même
Griezmann qui m'avait écrit en fait
parce qu'il y avait une question de ce
midi sur Griezmann et Griezmann m'avait
dit merci Jean-Luc pour pour d'avoir
parler de moi j'avais répondu ouais
voilà j'ai mis un petit message en
espagnol je me suis dit à l'Atletico
faut le mettre aussi un peu dans le bain
tu peux le mettre ici voilà on reste un
peu quand même dans les terres espagnols
bon et je suis sûr que Jean-Luc viens
prendre en tout cas me rappeler je te
dirai j'espère merci Louis d'avoir été
avec nous très drôle merci c'était très
drôle c'est pas possible
je t'ai rien demandé
[Applaudissements]